sixty fires are still burning in New
South Wales with predictions that the
worst is yet to come
three people have died and a hundred and
fifty homes have been destroyed in these
bush fires which have torn through the
east of Australia so anything with a
family we've got our lives and we have
great neighbors and friends all together
with temperatures expected to soar and
winds to change direction communities
here have been told to prepare for
catastrophic conditions as we've said
for decades now we cannot guarantee a
fire truck at every home we cannot
guarantee an aircraft will be overhead
every time a fire is impacting on your
property we cannot guarantee that
someone will knock on the door and give
you a warning that there's fires nearby
firefighters have been granted emergency
powers allowing them to control
government resources force evacuations
and shut down utilities they need to use
all means possible to fight these fires
here a home is totally surrounded by
flames dangerously close they've
accepted the advice of Commissioner
Fitzsimmons and declared a state of
emergency across New South Wales I want
to assure the people of New South Wales
that this is a precautionary stance this
is to make sure that we leave no stone
unturned to keep our communities safe
[Music]
bushfires are a common and deadly threat
in Australia's hot and dry summers this
current severe outbreak comes well
before the summer peak catching many by
surprise and calling into question the
strength of the country's policies on
climate change with weather conditions
expected to get worse
emergency services say Australia is
facing what could be its most dangerous
bushfires ever Charlotte Lomas Sky News